it's time for our deep dive at number
five after month event is a patient
today we get the details on the new
Apple watch at one p.m. eastern time
today the tech giant will begin its
first big event of the year and the
wearable is in focus but how successful
will the new device be for the company
and the tech sector overall my next
guest believes the Apple watch is a
major game changer for the industry and
says a product could kickstart
groundbreaking growth around wearables
for numerous tech vendors over the next
few years I want to bring in Daniel eyes
he's a managing director at fBR Capital
Markets so Dan why do you say this I
mean this is really the silver bullet
event product that not just consumers
but I think the overall technology feel
has been waiting for min apples the gold
standard of Technology so this watch
there's a lot riding on not just for
Apple but for the overall industry just
given who Apple is so the wearable
market is really looking at today to
being a catalyst to propel in the
industry right and as we were saying
before if Apple can't do it with this
then what forget about wearables for now
yeah i mean look there the modern-day
wright brothers so if apple can do it I
think there's the jury would be really
out on if the wearable market can take
off that's why even Samsung Microsoft
any technology company as well as a
whole ecosystem in terms of wearables
they want Apple wash to be successful
because that could really stimulate a
whole ecosystem over the coming years in
terms of the wearable market but have
terrible if you are the CEO of Samsung
or the CEO of sony that you have to look
your competitor to invigorate this
market because you yourself if you are a
samsung or sony you've already gone out
and sold wearables right i mean and we
know for a fact that the market was what
five million were sold last year hebbal
the inventor of the SmartWatch you could
say has sold only a million since 2013
so kind of like how pathetic that you
have to actually get your rival to start
this market I think they look in the
mirror and they have to recognize
reality is Apple is just miles ahead in
terms of just the overall technology and
they are core we
eater in this market should the
wearables you when you through a
Microsoft with hololens in just virtual
reality it's all really into wearables
because if you think about this market a
15 20 billion dollar potential market
down the road it all starts today where
Apple watch really needs to open up that
door for wearables and competitors like
it or not they really need Apple to be
the Trailblazer here and to get
consumers over the hump so it's three
hundred fifty dollars which is a rumored
price going to get consumers over the
hump I think the jury's out a little in
terms of what adoption will be and I
think it's not about if they sell 10
million or 30 million units it's more do
you finally see inflection point where
consumers core apple consumers go to the
watch you start to actually move the
needle and I think if that's successful
it's going to spawn an echo system of
more wearable technology apps but but
Apple really as we've seen you know
through the last decade plus right leave
it's hard to argue with what they've
done that's why a lot of people viewing
this wearable event as a huge inflection
point in the industry now you know you
mentioned that you know the projections
are what they could sell 10 to 15
million of these watches I know Apple
itself is going to into production
production it seems with about five to
six million of these watches but Dan all
of that is nothing compared to the 70
4.6 million iPhones that they sold in
just the last quarter it's not even the
bread the restaurant it's me hey olive
oil at the bread the restaurant that's
why it's not necessarily about if it's
moving the needle from a revenue
perspective it's about does this open up
a whole new category of Technology and I
think you guys think broader in terms of
wearables it's not just a watch it's
about virtual reality it's about other
wearable technologies about going into
the enterprise in terms of signs and
other enterprise applications and big
data right I think it's not necessarily
this in terms of what it's doing from a
revenue perspective as does is open up
an opportunity to 34 years for that you
know down the road well is there any
chance though and I don't know how I
mean I know it's going to work with the
iphone but
you know could it start to cannibalize
any of the sales at Apple not really
because you really need you were you
really need your actual phone to
actually work with the watch so I think
that's something they already thought
ahead in terms of any cannibalization of
Act I think when you look at some of the
other technology out there that could be
some cannibalization but at this point
for Apple it would be more incremental
and for the industry in terms as
wearable technology and that's why if we
look out next 6-9 months it's really
going to be key for the industry if this
is a successful and that's really a lot
of investors are looking at as well and
success for you and this on this watch
is going to be what that has a long
battery life that it has lots of apps to
be loaded on it I mean what would it
well first is the event just showing
that to use cases as well as the actual
technologies enough that consumers are
going to line up in the apple store
they're actually going to buy this
technology and then the actual success
will be measured in terms of technology
but really in terms of unit growth I
mean you start to get that 10 15 20
million that's where you start to get
right to the point where okay there is
some consumer adoption yeah but today
but I mean like in order for it to be a
success what do you think it absolutely
needs to have I I think it really has to
do with its integrating health ok and
it's really integrating more apps and
technology that a consumer could look at
a three hundred fifty dollar price point
and say I could rationalize bind that
it's going to help my life there's you
zzzz health would be the bottom of my
list and it's not because I'm not a
healthy person I try to be a healthy
person but I would say that if it made
it easier for me to pay something if it
made it easier for me to talk or you
know like then I would use it but that's
where Apple pay and you start to think
about where the technology could lead
eventually you have your watch you're
going to a deli you're paying with your
watch or paying with your wearables
that's what it's all going to open up
this whole other really a paradigm shift
in terms of consumers will they actual
you know they built the house when
consumers come